Don't starve!
Do Not. Just go get food.
Make food!
Duplicates have DIED?!
Virgil, NOOO!
God dammit, Virgil :(
Ooooh NOOO!
Hello everybody.
My name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Oxygen Not Included.
There was a problem where people were not making food.
There wasn't anything wrong with the food...
Like these were powered, everything was repaired...
Like they were working fine. But for some reason, they just were not...
They just were not making food!
And I DON'T KNOW why!
I have no idea why.
Why weren't they making food?
Oh, we're out of power, God dammit.
Oh, get on the power!
Oh my God, I can't believe that.
Why weren't they making food?
I don't know!
I just don't know why they weren't making food.
There's no reason that they shouldn't have.
I mean, stress was finally going down,
but now stress is up just because they're... They're out of...
Food!
Just Eat (x1)
Eat (x2)
Eat (x3)
Eat (x4)
Eat (x5)
EAT! (x6)
EAT! (x7)
Work Out!
Eat!
Put coal in this son of a bitch!
I don't know why it's so hard to do that!
Alright, everyone's running, which is good.
At least we're gonna build the batteries back up just manually.
Yeah, 'cause I know the Microbe Mushers probably take
oodles and oodles of power. And that's no good...
But, you can only do so much.
You have to get food. You just GOTTA!
No way you can't...
Why aren't people sweeping over here?
It's coal to be delivered, just gotta get the sweep!
Oh God, no!
SUKI!! :(
OH NO MEEP! :((
God Dammiiiit!
*sad sigh*
They starved to death.
God dammit.
*sad sigh*
Oh my God...
Oh my God! STOP!
They're just-
MAXX??!!
Yvette! Why were you..
You were TRAPPED up there?
I didn't know! :(
Oh Jesus!
Just when I thought-
Just when I thought everything was going BETTER!
Just when I thought, things were actually looking up...
Suddenly...
Things go down.
Now everyone's stressed because of the DEATHS!
So they're breaking things...
Just when we were pulling it back from the edge!
God dammit Max!
Max was my favorite!
I didn't mean to play favorites,
but Max WAS!
*sigh* But we gotta move on!
We gotta move on. I know everyone's stressed now...
We gotta build these memorials, so hopefully the dead bodies just aren't gonna be sitting there.
Jeez!
*another sigh*
Man, I'm honestly hurt by that!
I'm honestly hurt!
Of all the people to die,
I can't believe Max died.
Man, those take a LONG time to make.
And obviously not for a poor reason
Oh yeah I know, I know,
I know.
And now suddenly we're down helpers
so...
*sigh* Less work can get done.
So anyway,
for this episode, I really wanna bring it back to normal
I want everything to be working again,
and I think that was just...
That was just the blow that we had to deal with.
Like...
I don't know how else to make it better.
But I had a plan..
*Did!
I had a plan to make things work
And now with...
People gone...
God, that sucks...
You guys just aren't the SAME!
Guys just aren't the same!
Argh
Got Cecil, Woodrow-
Oh Woodrow! You remind me of MAX!
Oh, this duplicate is a little slow on the update,
but GOSH, do they TRY!
Ohhhh, Woodrow!
You're a good one too, but...
Ohh, he's a farty slow learner,
but he's robust and a grease monkey!
I can't fault him for that!
Woodrow, welcome on board.
God I'm, I'm like literally sad.
I'm legitimately sad about that.
I'm legitimately sad.
Ah, that's harsh.
God, and our- and our entire like, operation is suffering for this loss.
Like running out of power,
running (nrnrnr?!) out of everything.
I mean I can't keep this coal generator here
because it just makes too much carbon dioxide
Over here...
And it's not even working anyway!
Oh Woodrow you're trying real hard
I appreciate that, I really do!
Oh, I appreciate that.
I'm gonna make some-
I'm gonna make some outlets for people.
I'm just gonna,
like, this is gonna be...
a Goddamn-
This is gonna be the decor room.
They're gonna build one there.
It's gonna be just the art chamber.
Alright. And then canvases...
Hopefully this will help people deal with some stress.
And bring this room to decor maximum.
I know.
I know, I know, I know.
We're getting SOME al- we're getting some algae though, so that's nice.
We got a lot of slime.
We got...
We got three...
Megagrams of slime!
in storage, which should be more than enough.
'Cause these just take ten kilograms at a time.
So we're gonna have enough algae for a good while.
So that'll be good.
This thing needs to be repaired.
But s- only so long as these guys actually make it.
That's the problem here.
You're doing great Woodrow
I'm really proud of you Woodrow.
Woodrow is really bringing it together.
I'm gonna make um...
These stress relievers are gonna be a priorit-
Whoa, hey, whoa, hey.
I'm gonna make these stress relievers a priority here.
Yeah, I'd also like to do priority mop,
'cause there's just contaminated water everywhere.
Just from people vomiting!
Like that's literally all it is!
It's just people vomiting.
There's only so much you can do about that.
But you know,
I just wanna make sure that people actually have something to...
Go for it here.
Oh, there goes another one.
Stress vomiting, where was that?
Ok, all right then.
I know they're not happy with the sweeping,
but at least they're doing it.
Awww, Olive is eating at the mess table?
I haven't even seen someone there in ages.
Ah, that's so nice!
All right, go to bed guys.
You deserved it.
Come on Stinky!
Oh, come on Stinky!
Go to bed, Sa- You can break it tomorrow!
I won't even be mad if you break it tomorrow.
Just go to bed, buddy.
You can relax.
Man, I feel like I'm talking to my family here
more than I'm talking to you guys!
Oh man!
I don't mean to.
It's just like these guys, they-
Like, I remember 'em all,
and Nori is just a champ, a constant champ.
Like I'll remember Max, and uh like,
these gravestones, that they have.
Lenny, Virgil, Meep... Max :'(
and Suki! Suki was so good, too!
Oh, Suki was so good.
I dunno.
I just-
I remember 'em like I'm,
It's weird. I'm growing attached to these guys.
That's why I didn't want to leave them behind!
That's why I didn't want to just start over. I wanted to like,
help 'em.
I wanted to actually do this for them.
You know, I wanted them to be able to do this.
And hopefully...
All those things up there are gonna be able to relieve the stress,
but everyone's still stressed anyway.
Man, we're running out of oxygen
We need more algae.
We GOTTA get those algae producers up.
Oh, they're out of power,
that's the problem.
Okay.
*sigh*
All right. We gotta prioritize some power here.
Ok.
Well, they're busy breaking 'em.
So that's nice.
At least- She tuckered out before she could finish it!
Oh, he broke one, and he started running in the other! Oh, that's so nice.
Oh, Stinky! Like I said, I'm not actually mad at you-
Oh, you tuckered out before you could finish? Oh, there you go.
Right back to it. That's a champ.
That's a champ right there.
All right, so what I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna- I'm gonna keep playing for a bit.
I'm gonna get back to a point,
till we at least get back to where we were before everyone died.
Would be awfully nice,
but I don't know how long it's gonna take,
but we're gonna get there, guys.
We're gonna get there. All right,
so that's a little better. I'm gonna bring everything back down to 5.
Just so everything is 5.
Everything's 5, everything's 5, everything's 5.
It's just I want everything to be normal.
And no one to really to prioritize anything.
Over the others.
Not yet anyway.
Batteries are ALL full, actually.
Every single battery is full, that's nice.
So now, I'm gonna raise these Bio Distillers to SIX, and hopefully that'll do something.
Stress is still high, still high.
Here, I can do something for 'em here because,
I wanna make uh, an easier way of travel... through here?
Just so there's a way to go through on the inside.
That people don't have to worry about it.
All right. We've got another problem coming soon.
Water...
That's an obvious problem.
'K. These things are finally cooling down to the point where they can actually grow, which is nice.
It'll get there sooner.
Um, it's just gonna be a little bit.
And they're relieving stress but decorating, which is nice.
Man, I just don't know why these things aren't getting filled.
New person, all right!
What have we got?
Whoa...
What happened there?
New person.
Who we got?
Zeke, Pierre, and... Chuanli.
Twinkle Toes, Night Owl...
Quick Learner and Narcoleptic.
Zeke the Bodybuilder, huh?
Kinda li- I...
I like narcoleptics. I think it's cute.
Plus you get extra sleep whenever you need it.
WHOA, what is that? A Morb?
Morb?? Oh GOD.
A Morb is on Yvette's BODY.
What the FUCK?
"Agile, disease-ridden invertebrate... attracted to decomposing carcasses of deceased organisms".
Ughhh.
UGHHHH!
That's morbid! That's why it's called a Morb.
Oh boy.
God dammit. Just, convert algae!
We have so much slime. Just do it!
These are *sigh*
These are top priority. I don't know why it's not working.
I do not understand what's going on here.
There's slime.
They're not putting it in the slime-
In the Bio Distillers. They're just not doing it!
Why aren't they doing it?
I'm just gonna put this right by it.
And I'm gonna have 'em destroy this.
I'm gonna have 'em destroy...
Like this. And it's just gonna pump contaminated oxygen here, but
what else can I do?
Like *sigh*
I don't know what else it wants from me.
Can someone, please, just put them in the...
Put it in the Goddamn Bio Distiller.
Why is no one putting it in the Goddamn Bio Distiller??
This should be working...
It's right there!
What more do you WANT?
WE NEED ALGAE! WE HAVE TO HAVE IT!
Everything's just going to shit,
because they will not put the fucking slime in the Bio Distiller!
PLEASE! I'm begging you guys...
Just, put it in!
That's ALL it takes!
Everything else is baseline priority, except for that!
Wait...
Maybe...
Maybe this whole time...
Because I didn't have outpoint vents-
Maybe it was... full?
And not pumping?
Is that what it was?
I hope, I hope that's what it was. Because if that is, maybe...
Maybe...
But maybe, that's a BIG maybe...
At least I got the puff up here doing its thing.
That was it??
THAT WAS IT???
THAT WAS IT!!
THAT WAS IT, OMG THAT WAS IT!!!
OH!
Oh, oh, oh! That was it! It didn't have an outflow!
Of COURSE it didn't!
OH NO!
Oh no!
That's what it was? They didn't have vents!
OH MY GOD!
THIS WHOLE TIME...
This whole time, we could've had ALL the algae we needed!
And I was too much of an idiot!
*oh no*
But at least...
At the very least, we're gonna have what we need.
*oh man* We BETTER... We better survive long enough for this algae production to go into effect.
Hello, new person! It's still hell!
Mae, Joshua, or Eleanor...
"Naturally Robust"
That sounds good.
We could use a physician that doesn't get sick!
It's awfully good for us.
This is good.
This is good! It's FINALLY FLOWING!
We're finally able to make oxygen now!
I- It's FINALLY WORKING!
And then hopefully these are gonna get up and running,
because we need to.. deal. We need these to deal with the carbon dioxide, but...
Oh my God!
If this actually finally works again,
I'm gonna be so happy...
That I'm gonna lose my Goddamn mind!
And I'm gonna make another stor-
Well, I'm just gonna make one of these...
This is raw material, and also algae...
And this shit.
Actually, not- not... Let's not make that one contaminated.
Actually, not *mumbling*
That's where the contaminated *more mumbling*
Ok. So what I'm doing is,
I'm- I'm gonna make...
I'm gonna solve all our problems all at once, because
Number one: This puft, uh up here is at the top.
And contaminated oxygen likes to flow upwards,
I'm gonna eventually replace this with VENTS.
Uhh....
No, I'm not gonna do Gas Permeable Tiles there.
Umm...
Building meltdown?
Buildi- Wait. What is a building meltdown?
WHAT ITA- Ugh God dammit. All right, whatever. Fine. It's fine...
But...
What I'm gonna do is,
This...
Uhhh, these are gonna dump their contaminated water down here.
And then I'm gonna put a pump here, to push water out this way.
I'm eventually gonna reroute these over here, too.
I'm gonna build all this out.
But so the contaminated water's over here,
'cause slime is regurgitated into contaminated water.
This thing constantly pumps out slime.
It pumps out a lot of slime.
So that's a constant supply of slime.
And then that get recycled over here, turned into water-
I'm gonna PURIFY the water...
Into good water. 'Cause we're almost out of water, which is very bad.
And then everything is gonna be Ok.
Right? That's how this works. Maybe.
I shouldn't have killed that puft.
This all wouldn't have happened if I had not killed that puft.
That is the one thing...
This is gonna be where the bridge is.
I'm just putting tile there, so I can put pipe through it without liquids flowing through...
'Cause eventually I'm gonna reroute these. So that's fine.
'Cause I can just reroute these to shunt over there without to much issue.
I suppose you can just build right through that.
*Oh Jesus, what happened...*
Ok. So, you can NOT do that. You can't lay pipe where wire is.
That is a big no-no.
Ok. So, pipe and wire can't go together.
That's fine.
That is fine.
That's 100% fine.
We're almost outta slime.
God dammit.
How can we almost be out of slime?
I thought that was supposed to last us a long time!
Not that anyone told me that that was the case, but just because it was something that I assumed.
I'm not giving up yet.
Not giving up yet.
Not giving up yet!
Gus died in an explosion??
What?
What explosion??
How do you d-
How did Gus die in an explosion??
WHAT??
How did that even happen? How does something explode??
Oh Jesus.
All right.
I'll be back. I'm still working on it.
I'm getting there.
It's gonna happen.
*It's now or never*
I was saving this last pocket of algae,
for just such an occasion such as this, where everything has gone to shit.
And I'm in the middle of fixing it.
So, what I'm doing here is, I'm...
I'm creating multiple stages of walls because I need to uh get rid of....
I need to uh...
I need to um...
Keep the water in here while also create what I need to be able to build um everything else.
So this, this has to be made uh SOON, just because...
It is very essential.
But I'm blocking up everything so that this will be its own contained unit.
I'm gonna get rid of this and create a new wall here.
So this is just contained in where it is
I'm gonna move all these stuff,
But I gotta do this first
So that way, I'll have a giant pool of
contaminated water, and then this will act as the bridge
to filter it.
It's not IDEAL, I know
'Cause I've also got lot of water here I need to mop this,
Just to get rid of this,
I need to mop this, I need to mop-
Oh, Jeez, that is the last of the water
I need to mop That,
This has to be moped,
All these stuff has to be MOPED,
They're gonna get that,
*yeesh*
So then, when that's built
which is almost SOON,
They'll be able to do that
They're moping that,
That's like it!
They're doing that first, which I really appreciate.
That is the last of the good water,
Maybe,
We've got some food,
*yeesh*
Ok, the algae starts to going back 'cause we got this little bit of algae
I'm assuming that's what filtered into filtered into everything
Oh Jeez!
Goddammit
someone's shit there
Ok
So the water purifier is there,
That's gonna be..
Top priority.
We are...
Officially out of slime apparently,
So we got very little slime left,
I don't think this one Puft is gonna be able to make enough...
Make enough slime
So we gotta dig more soon but not right now
I gotta worry about the water first.
Oh they're taking the contaminated water. *augh*
Alright we gotta...
I've gotta nullify everything back down
to base
priority.
Just because I don't want them to starve to death
They gotta go do their thing.
Oh Boy, another one!
Bring him into the fold!
"uncultured"
Hey! Nice!
He is a Yokel, Twinkletoe and uncultured!
That'll do good for me!
Come on in, Virgil!
Alright Virgil, we got work to do.
Ok,
So I've got a pump here,
It's not pumping though,
Why?
It's powered?
Yes, It is powered.
It's submerged in water,
Which was a requirement
"Must be submerged in water to-" continue.
Why did that break?!
Why did that break?
Why did that break?!?
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
Why did that break!?!?
What the Hell just happened there?!
"Nominal", "Contents",
Why is this not pumping?
Why did that break?
I'm gonna reinforce that just in case, 'cause that is weird.
That should not have happened.
"Filtration Medium"!
Ah, Ok, so it needs a filtration medium.
So I know we have sand,
We've got a lot of sand,
We got too much sand.
"Awaiting material delivery"
Obviously
So it needs sand
So who's gonna give it sand?
Oh! I got'em backwards!
Oh, that's what it is.
That's the "out", that's the "in".
Oh I had'em backwards. Ok, that's- that's what's wrong.
Ok.
So now that I know that,
Let me get outta this overlay,
Ah, so this was going in the wrong entrance
ok so,
I need to...
instead...
Put the plumbing...
This goes in,
Dammit, God dammit,
Ah...
This makes things difficult.
How the fuck do you do that then?!
Ok,
And then this
goes from there
oh no, actually first let me just
NO, no, no, no. Do not. Do NOT
Yeah, don't con- deconstruct that, ok.
So NOW
I'm gonna put these at high priority
because I need this...
to work please!
Ok, so then the "out"
is gonna go
over here.
Maybe it'll work,
maybe that'll work.
Let me just assume that that's gonna work.
Before I go saying nothing's gonna work.
Ok, so we definitely got stuff flowing through now.
I see that.
So it's gonna do it's thing..
Oooh! We're starting to process apparently.
Come on! finish it, finish it, finish it, finish it!
You're so close!
Oh, one more. Come on!
There we go. Ok!
And theeeen..
We just need to...
Yeah!
And then, That's IT!
Whoa! Hey!
Whoa (x1)
Whoa (x2)
Whoa (x3)
Whoa (x4)
Whoa (x5)
OK!
Whoa (x6)
Whoa (x7)
Jesus Christmas!!
Gemini Christmas! That works way faster than I thought it would!
What the Fuuuudge?!!
Ok, we got a new person coming in,
hang on! Let's slow things down just a hair.
Ok. Gus, Hideki and McNair..
"Yokel", "flatulence",
"uncultured". I like McNair!
McNair, Come on in here McNair!
Holy Shit! Alright then.
Ok, so we got the water pump working
Uh.. A lot apparently. That's-
That's much different than I thought it would be because
God, it's really intermixed but that-
That's working FAST!
It's filtering 600 grams per second
That's so weird!
But it's WORKING!
It IS in fact working
which is good- God, everything is broken again.
That is working insanely well.
mm, better than I ever thought it was gonna work.
Ok, but WITH THIS,
WITH THIS,
I now should have a steady stream of water
with which to make my base out of.
I SHOULD!
It SHOULD- SHOULD be that!
It SHOULD be that.
So, this is good.
So I'm gonna end the episode here.
Been recording this one for about over and hour, but it hasn't felt like this.
Because I'm having the time of my life playing this game.
I'm almost there. I'm SO close to getting where I need to be!
I'm so close!
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see YOU
IN THE NEXT VIDEO!
BUH-BYE!